whether you're trying to get into law or
you're trying to get into accounting or
you're trying to get into video editing
or you're trying to get into sales or
you're trying to get into marketing
whatever the core activity that you do
making videos making ads writing sales
Pages actually doing sales calls
whatever it is if you do two times or
four times the volume you will get
better faster and pay down your
ignorance debt at a faster rate that
can't bounds Kobe Bryant was famous for
doing this where he would do two
practices a day and he thought if
everybody else does one practice today I
will get better faster and in the
beginning the difference is not that
notice but after 5 years and then 10
years he becomes unbeatable he has
compounded the number of hours in the
trenches learning the thing